[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMIE JONES: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jamie, Jamie Jones and I'm
a professor in Earth System
Science at Stanford.
I'm actually trained
as an anthropologist,
but I sit in the School
of Earth, Energy,
and the Environment at
Stanford in the Department
of Earth System Science.
So today I'm going to talk to
you about some recent interest
I've had in applying
evolutionary and ecological
ideas to economics
and decision theory.
This interest was
piqued by my attempt
to understand the peculiarities
of the human life cycle,
and our life cycles are really
peculiar, I can assure you.
In a broad, comparative context,
they're really kind of weird.
And to understand the reason
people in subsistence economies
pursue particular
types of resources--
prey and forage food
and that sort of thing.
And so I'm going to guide
you through a big picture
view of some fairly
technical fields today
that include population
biology, decision theory,
a bit of economics, both
classical and behavioral.
But I think the ultimate message
is pretty straightforward,
and the thing that's sort of
broad picture that motivates me
is understanding how
something like this, which
is an artist's reconstruction
of "Australopithecus
afarensis," which is
essentially a one-meter tall
chimpanzee-like thing
that walked upright.
It's got a 300-cubic
centimeter brain,
so about a quarter
of the size of--
maybe a little less than
a contemporary human.
Very sexually
dimorphic-- the males
are much bigger
than the females.
They had enormous cheek teeth
from eating a very tough diet,
and as I said,
they're really tiny.
These guys lived about 3
and 1/2 million years ago
in East Africa, and
transition in this
probably doesn't look that
different, I guess, but it is.
It's fundamentally different.
In about 1 and 1/2,
1.8 million years ago.
And this critter, called "Homo
regaster," for my purposes,
is effectively modern.
You've got a large body size,
so within the normal range
of contemporary human variation.
You've got body proportions that
looked very much like people
living in the tropics today.
You've got a great reduction
in sexual size dimorphism,
so that males and females are
similarly proportioned to how
they are today
relative to each other,
and you've got big brains.
They're not-- they're
smaller than modern,
but they're actually within
the range of variation--
on the low end of variation
of contemporary humans.
"Homo regaster," sometimes
called "African Homo erectus,"
is the first of our
family to leave Africa
and to colonize the
rest of the world.
And it did so around
1.8 million years ago,
give or take a little bit.
And so my question is, how is
it that a population of bipedal
apes-- you know, they're not
very impressive looking, right?
Kind of like we aren't, right?
We don't have big weapons.
We don't have antlers or horns.
We don't have big teeth.
We don't have this sort
of ferocity built into us.
We have some cleverness, maybe.
But how is it that in
less than 2 million years,
which is a very rapid period
of time in the broader span
of evolution-- how is it that we
went from this small population
of African apes--
bipedal apes-- and have grown
to a size of 7 billion souls
in, as I say less than
1.8 million years?
And we've colonized and
come to dominate nearly
every terrestrial biomome.
This is just a picture of making
the desert green in the Arabian
Peninsula as a sort of indicator
of the extent to which we
really dominate the world.
30% to 40% of net
primary productivity
is captured by human
actions, right?
So the phenomenal
growth of our species
in this very short
period of time
suggests that our
ancestors on average
must have made pretty
good decisions, right?
Because the decisions
they made led
them to increase in
pretty great numbers.
But there's a torrent
of work in psychology
and economics, represented by
just a few sample publications
here of semi-popular
trade books,
suggest that the decision-making
software that our brains run,
which is presumably essential
to our ecological domination,
is profoundly flawed.
That in a word,
we're irrational.
How is it possible that a
species apparently so defective
in its ability to
generate sound decisions
can be so incredibly
evolutionarily successful?
I'll just say as a
relative outsider,
I'll make this observation about
this particular body of work
that I'm discussing
here in this slide.
There are lots of
anomalies, like we
see these things
that don't make sense
from the way we sort of
think about the way people
should make decisions, and you
can write whole books on this--
lots of books on this.
But they're generally
unconnected,
and the whole area seems
to lack a unifying theory.
I'm going to humbly submit that
I think that evolution can help
us provide some of the
theory that brings together
some of these anomalies.
There's a tendency, in
particular, like in the Ted
Talks where there's
real selection for being
provocative, to
suggest that people
are irrational
because they don't
follow the rules of formal or
axiomatic rationality theory.
However, every economic
decision entails an optimization
problem, and I feel
like I'm on safe ground
when I'm at Google talking
about optimization problems.
That if you want to solve
an optimization problem,
what do you need?
Well, you need to know
who's doing the optimizing.
You need to know
the actor, but you
need to know the
objective function, right?
And if you get the
objective function wrong,
you're going to get
the solution wrong.
And it doesn't matter what
your optimization problem is.
It could be an
engineering problem,
it could be a portfolio design--
an investment portfolio design.
It could be about getting the
best mixture of wild foods
to ensure growth and survival.
But you need to get the
objective function right,
and I'm going to suggest
that in general, we
don't have a very solid
understanding of what
the objective function
is that people
are using when they're making
economic decisions broadly.
OK, and their results
appear anomalous.
When you use the wrong
objective function,
you get the wrong
answer, and I think
that evolution helps weave
together theoretically
what are otherwise a series
of unconnected anomalies.
So we lack this
coherence, and I think
these may be brought
together if we understand
what sort of problems the
human brain is actually
designed to solve.
Get the right objective
function and you have a chance--
a chance.
I'm not 100% convinced of this.
This is fairly new
for me, but I feel
like there's a real chance
that we can begin to understand
the broader theory of choice.
So the two things that
we really need, I think,
are evolutionary theory, which
guides our choice of what's
being optimized.
It gives us a clue as to what
the likely objective function
that our brains are designed
to solve, or to optimize.
And secondly, it's
really important
that we get broad
comparative data
to help us understand
the conditions that
favor your decision-making.
It turns out that
different groups of people
make more or less
good decisions, right?
It's not everybody
who's a complete idiot
and behaves irrationally,
and we sort of
limit ourselves a lot
in the sort of people
that we inquire about
decision-making.
I'm going to focus primarily
on the evolutionary theory
and give you just some
hints of some work
that we've done
without getting bogged
down in the technical
details, but I
think that the comparative data
is really important, as well.
I'm going to use
this word "fitness."
I'm going to use it a lot,
and evolutionary success
is determined by fitness,
and the problem with fitness
is it's one of these
super-fraught terms that
has lots of
colloquial meanings--
that can kind of interfere
with our rigorous understanding
and analysis of it.
So when I talk
about fitness, I'm
talking about the
relative contribution
that an individual makes
to future populations.
So if you have some
heritable trait,
whether it's anatomical or
physiological or behavioral,
marginally increasing the
representation of its bearers
and future generations,
the population
is going to evolve
towards that trait.
This is the fundamental
logic of selection,
and fitness is the evolutionary
objective function.
It is the subject of
evolutionary optimization,
so just wanted to get
that out of the way.
I'm going to give you a
quick preview of the approach
that we use in thinking
about this more formally.
The organs that make
our economic decisions--
they're organs, just
like our liver is, just
like our heart is.
Presumably these have been
under intense selection,
and part of the reason--
just as an aside-- part
of the reason we think
that brains should
be under intense
selection is not just
because they're useful, but
because they're super costly,
right?
The brain is an incredibly
costly thing to carry around.
It entails mortality
costs for mothers,
because if we've got the
cephalopelvic disproportion,
big brains have to come
through a limited pelvic cavity
when they're born.
Brains use 20% of
oxygen at rest.
They're super costly.
The fact that they
exist and that they've
gotten bigger over time
suggests that there's
a reason they're there, right?
So people with good
decision-making capabilities
presumably, in
the past, resulted
in leaving more descendants
and became disproportionately
represented in the population.
To the extent that economic
decisions affect fitness,
we should expect outcomes to
track fitness interests more
than some arbitrarily defined
standard of formal rationality.
So let me just walk you through
a little bit of the logic here
of the model, and then I'm
going to move away from it
and go onto talking
about some features
of the human
evolutionary environment.
So it's a hierarchical model.
At the bottom, we have
economic decisions.
These are about the sort
of things you hunt for,
the sort of things you
put in your market basket,
the decisions you're making
on a day-to-day basis
about your livelihood, and these
feed into what we think of as
like proximate motivators.
These are the things that
you're sort of striving
for in a proximate way--
happiness or sexual
gratification or satiety--
the things that motivate
you to eat or to have sex
or to do things that are
meaningful in your life.
But these, then presumably
have an impact on fitness,
and we can think of fitness
here as an aggregator--
something that aggregates and
averages over these different--
uh, my pointer doesn't work--
these different
goals which are fed
into by these
economic decisions.
So that's a preview of the type
of reasoning that we're using.
I'll come back to
this in a little bit,
but I do want to
mention-- you know,
I said that the two
things that we need--
I think we need
evolutionary theory.
I think we also need
broad comparative data
on the decision-making of actual
people, and particularly people
who are good at making decisions
under tremendous constraints,
and this is just a selection
of a bunch of people.
They've written some
books, and it turns out
that, somewhat to
the surprise of much
of the institution of studying
economic decision-making,
that poor people often make
incredibly savvy decisions.
They face enormous constraints,
but when you adjust for that--
when you control for the fact
that their constraint set is
very limited--
that their strategy
set is very limited
and they're under
tremendous constraint--
poor people tend to make
very good decisions, in part
because it really
matters to them.
And so I'm going to
leave that-- this
is another big part of the
broader work that I'm doing,
but I want to focus on
more of the evolution part.
The economic decisions I'm
going to talk about and show
you some pictures of typically
center on subsistence
populations, and the things
look a little exotic.
But the sorts of decisions
that people make in subsistence
economies are fundamentally
no different than the types
of decisions that we
make on a regular basis.
How do you fill your market
basket, given a fixed budget?
It may not be money.
It may be time.
It may be political capital,
but you're doing very much
the same sort of thing.
And basically, my
argument is that we
have to think about humans
as biological entities.
We've been shaped
by selection, and
that our decision-making
capabilities have fundamentally
been shaped by this
evolutionary heritage.
To a biological entity,
economic decisions
are not arbitrary
preference orderings,
which is sort of the
way you typically
will learn about them in
a microeconomics class,
for example.
It turns out that the rules
for a living organism--
anchored in the present
and subject to a force
of selection-- that really
doesn't like extinction, right?
Fitness is a
multiplicative process.
In order for your
lineage to persist,
it has to persist
every generation.
You can't get a zero in there
or it's an absorbing boundary,
so you really want
to avoid those zeros.
I'll show that the
all-important need
to avoid extinction in a world
that's incompletely known
at best has profound
implications for preferences,
utility, and rationality.
And one of the key things I
think that comes out of this
is that ignoring the condition
of existential uncertainty--
by doing that, the theory
of rational decision-making
has developed a
distorted expectation
of how organisms working
in their own interest
should behave.
OK, so a bunch of the
work I've done on this
is in collaboration
with my colleagues
Rebecca and Doug Bird.
And just to give you a
sampling of the types
of economic decisions we
tend to think about, do you
hunt for goanna, which are
these monitor lizards that
live in the desert
of Western Australia,
or do you a hunt
for hill kangaroo?
There are different payoffs.
There are different risks
associated with this.
If you're a
subsistence farmer in--
this is in Uganda, another
place where I work,
do you plant maize,
do you plant yams,
or do you forego subsistence
crops altogether and take
a stab at the cash economy?
This is coffee.
Working with a post-doc, Ashley
Hazel, in southern Africa
in Namibia, we're asking
the sort of questions--
how do people,
particularly women, manage
social relationships to
manage the extreme uncertainty
of living in
essentially a desert
and trying to raise cattle,
trying to raise crops,
trying to raise children,
trying to keep yourself going
in a very difficult environment.
So these are the types
of economic decisions
that I tend to think
about, but as I say,
they're fundamentally no
different than going shopping,
buying a house-- doing
the sort of things
that economists tend to look at.
The history of this for me goes
back to my former PhD student
Mike Price, who is now a
post-doc at the Santa Fe
Institute, and Mike was
interested in understanding
the origins of sago palm
farming in Southeast Asia.
Sago palm-- it's
an amazing crop.
It's one of the centers
of agricultural innovation
around New Guinea in
the South Pacific--
Southeast Asia.
A single sago palm tree
will net literally millions
of calories in
starchy flour that you
can make into a gruel that's
very calorically dense.
The catch is it takes
25 years for a sago palm
to develop to maturity
and to the point where
it can be harvested,
and trying to understand
the evolution of this
remarkable horticultural system
led us to think hard about
economic topics, such as time
and risk preferences and
economic decisions generally.
It's hard to make a
standard economic model that
says, OK, forego the immediate
reward activities you're
pursuing right now and
go plant some sago palm,
and wait 25 years.
That's a hard problem
to solve, but clearly it
happened at some point.
So that's where all this
really started thinking,
and Mike and I have
been working together
for a few years on this stuff.
So a theme that
emerged in our work
is that a biological entity
trying to maximize fitness
will behave in ways
that often really mimic
the anomalies that you see
in this behavioral economics
and psychology literature.
We weren't looking to show
that, but we found how--
people said hey, that kind
of looks like [INAUDIBLE] I
thought, really?
That surprises me.
So they'll do things like
use non-expected utility.
I won't get into what
that necessarily means.
After we'll talk about it later.
They'll frequently violate
the axioms of rational choice.
They'll seemingly have
inconsistent time preferences.
And from the perspective
of an economic decision,
these may appear irrational,
but these behaviors
are the sort of
things that keep you
alive in a variable and
uncertain environment.
So rather than the
mathematicians'
formal axiomatic
rationality, people
seem to use a
procedural rationality,
and this is a point that
the great polymath economist
Herbert Simon suggested
in his scissors metaphor,
that trying to understand
decision-making
is like trying to understand
the way a pair of scissors work.
You've got on the one hand,
the computational capacities,
but on the other hand, you've
got the task environment.
Trying to understand the
computational capacities,
like the logical
rules of cognition,
without understanding
the environment,
is like trying to understand
half a pair of scissors--
doesn't work very well.
I said that there's selection
in Ted Talk-like environments
for saying provocative
things, and this is
a slightly provocative thing.
Darwin's saying it.
Economics isn't
actually a science.
And this isn't
meant as a put-down.
It's a statement
of fact, and it's
because the preferred
and overwhelmingly--
the dominant mode of economic
theory generation is axiomatic,
and that's not the way the
natural sciences proceed.
Behavioral economics
and this great field
of experimental
developmental economics
has changed this by actually
measuring the way people behave
rather than specifying
the way that they're
expected to behave, but
I think there's still
a decent amount of baggage.
What do I mean when
I say "axiomatic?"
Standard economic
theory generation
starts from a series of axioms--
primitive assumptions are
taken to be self-evident.
Things like, you shouldn't
reverse your preferences.
If you prefer A to
B and B to C, you
should prefer A to C. That's
an axiom of transitivity,
and that makes total sense.
But there's nothing that
guarantees that that's right.
There's nothing that
guarantees that that's
the way the universe works.
It's just a logical rule that
we say, I can live with that.
And so you take
these axioms, you
derive out the way you expect
a rational agent to behave,
and this is what economic
theory really is all about.
It's normative.
It describes how
actors should behave.
Science, on the other
hand, is positive.
It starts from observations
about the world
and attempts to explain them as
inferred through observed data.
It's inductive.
The theory plays the role
of generating hypotheses
which can then be confronted
with additional data.
And so it's a common and
it's a well-stated critique
that neoclassical
economic theory describes
the behavior of a species
other than humans,
and it's referred
to tongue-in-cheek
by the fake Latin binomial,
"Homo oeconomicus."
And while it's true
that humans do not
behave according to the
classical expectations,
or these neoclassical
expectations,
the expectations weren't
designed to actually explain
observed behavior, so we
shouldn't be that surprised
by it, I think.
So I'm going to
talk to you about--
right now for a
little bit about what
I think the really
important bits
of our human evolutionary legacy
are for understanding the way
we make decisions
about things, and I'm
going to dive down fairly deep
into my specialty area, which
is called life history theory.
So I'm going to suggest
that humans are adapted
to environmental uncertainty,
and this is, I think,
a pretty telling graphic.
So what I've got here is--
it's temperature proxy data,
so this is inferred
temperature by a million years
before present, so we're
going from more ancient
to more recent.
Humans are a product of what's
called the Pleistocene, which
is a geological epoch
that spans from about 1.8
million years ago to
about 10,000 years ago,
and the two things
that should be really
obvious from this
plot are that one,
the earth has cooled in the
last five million years.
It's actually cooled
considerably more
in the last 25 million years.
It's cooled and it's
gotten more variable,
and you can't actually
see it on here.
We know that in places,
particularly in Africa
where there's been a
lot of interest in this,
there's actually a decadal
scale variation here--
like enormous
environmental variation
going on that really gets
amplified in this period where
our genus emerged, which
is this pink line here.
And just while I'm on the
subject of temperature--
global temperature--
you'll sometimes
see people say, well,
you know, the Earth
used to be much warmer.
We can let it get warm.
It will be fine.
Maybe, sure.
But we're a cold
planet species, right?
We are adapted to
a cooler planet.
Just something to bear in mind.
The origin story of
the human lineage,
and the genus "Homo"
in particular,
is a story of moving from a
primarily arboreal lifestyle
in tropical ever-moist forests--
this is a chimpanzee foraging
for-- you can see the fruits
up in the top of the picture
there in the Nyungwe
Forest in Rwanda.
We moved from these
forests onto this sort
of mixed scrub savanna.
This is a picture from
the Serengeti National
Park in Tanzania.
And moving onto the
savanna entailed
a bunch of new challenges.
There are big predators there.
There are a lot of them.
They're big and they're scary.
But it also changes the
way food is distributed.
Here's a picture of a chimpanzee
who was in the Kibale National
Park, and he's
looking down at me,
and he's got an enormous
pile of figs here.
And this tree--
I don't want to exaggerate,
but it certainly
had tens of thousands of figs,
possibly hundreds of thousands,
possibly well into the
hundreds of thousands of figs.
These tropical figs are
incredibly productive.
They're asynchronous
breeders, so they
breed throughout the year.
They fruit throughout the year.
They're not really high quality.
You wouldn't want to make
a Newton out of them.
You're not going to
make figgy pudding
with these, because they
taste like crap, I assure you.
But when there's no good
fruit in the forest,
chimps will happily
eat this, and this
is in general what
the great apes do.
They fall back when their
preferred foods aren't there,
onto this lower quality stuff,
and figs are a great thing
in any tropical forest.
When you go out
into the savanna,
there isn't much fruit.
What there are are
underground storage organs.
So these are a bunch
of Hadza tubers
that my former post-doc
Brian Wood took a picture of,
and they look like
sticks, don't they?
Doesn't that look delicious?
Try to eat that and you're going
to spend like 12 hours just
chewing on it.
Your jaws are going
to be so tired.
You have to have fire,
basically, in order to--
you scorch them.
You burn them and you
make them chewable.
There's a lot of
stored starch in there,
and it makes for a
great fallback food,
but they're very
different than figs.
They're widely distributed.
They're not at all clumped.
You're never going
to find a patch--
you know, just start digging.
Oh, yeah, and you've
got to dig for them,
because they're underground.
But you've got to start digging.
You're not going to find
100,000 tubers there, right,
like you're going to find
100,000 figs in a tree.
So you have to spread
out your effort.
It changes the economics
of forging tremendously.
And here's Brian, who
is one of the world
authorities on the Hadza
hunter-gatherers in Tanzania,
and his hair really
is fascinating,
so he gets that a lot.
He's now a professor
down at UCLA.
So moving from the forests
to the savanna and beyond
increases the variability
in food intake,
because it's a
drier environment.
It's a less-productive
environment.
There are lots of opportunities
but there are also
lots of challenges.
And while there's certainly
more meat on the hoof,
your ability to manage
your downside, I think,
is much harder on the savanna.
And so this is why
adaptation to uncertainty
is a central part
of being human.
Humans move out of the
forest onto the savanna
and it's a much
more variable place,
and this variability
is not just--
you don't just like
set up an experiment,
measure the variability, and
get your nice distribution
that you fit to it, and say OK.
14% of the time,
I'm going to have
to do this, and 27%
of time, I'm going
to have to do this the way
a risk manager would do it.
There's real uncertainty here.
You really don't know
what the probabilities
are, in part because
the environment very
rapidly changing.
So when I say uncertainty, I
mean uncertainty and not risk.
Adaptation to uncertainty
is central to being human.
There all these things that
we do that are very unusual.
We have an expanded
diet, as I've mentioned,
that typically requires
technology to extract,
like these underground
storage organs.
We are the mobile primate.
Our home ranges, for
like a hunter-gatherer,
is on the order
of 10 to 100 times
bigger than a comparable-sized
chimpanzee group, OK?
So like the Hadza range over
about 2,500-square kilometers,
whereas a chimpanzee group
will range over about 20.
Now the chimps live in a forest,
so there is that difference,
but that's part of moving
out onto the savanna where
the Hadza live.
Humans are so mobile, when
things get really bad,
we get up and we
move continents.
This is very much a
timely issue, right?
The 21st century and the
latter part of the 21st century
is going to be dominated
by human mobility.
We see that it's breaking
lots of international systems
right now and possibly leading
to the rise of right wing
extremism.
Migration is part of our
story from the outset.
The other really big
thing that we do,
that we're really known for
and that's very unusual,
is we share food.
And it's so unusual-- we don't
even think about how weird is.
That a bunch of
unrelated males--
it doesn't matter--
males, females--
can sit in a room and
share food together and not
want to kill each other.
I mean, I don't know.
I don't want speak
for you, but I
can sit in a room with people.
People are eating.
I don't feel like I need to go
get all dominant or something.
This is weird, right?
You talk about your dog
and, oh, the unconditional
love of a dog.
I've got an idea.
Why don't you try pulling your
dog's food bowl away and eating
from it?
See if that love is so
unconditional, right?
It's a weird thing
that people do.
We share food all the time,
and hunter-gatherers-- it
turns out to be a super
risky and uncertain endeavor
to go hunting.
Those hill kangaroos-- 85% of
all hunting bouts end with zero
calories netted--
85%.
So these are mixed
hunter-gatherers
in the Canadian Arctic.
My student Elspeth Ready
gathered these data heroically
over two years.
It's an incredible,
incredible story,
and it's just to show you--
I mean, she also makes
really pretty graphics,
but it's just to show
you that by having
these networks of
food sharing, you
ensure against you
failing on any given day.
You can count on getting
food from someone else.
So this is also a
very unusual thing
that people do, and this
is part of the argument
for this embodiment of-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do
the colors mean?
JAMIE JONES: So the red
houses are food insecure,
and the blue ones
are food secure.
It's actually-- yeah, yeah.
It's actually a very
complicated graphic.
I just show it
because it's nice.
So those are a few ways
we manage uncertainty,
but my main focus is on the
evolution of our life cycles.
How long we live.
Why we reproduce when we do.
The patterns of reproduction--
that sort of thing.
And I would suggest
that uncertainty
is embodied fundamentally
in our reproductive biology.
Humans are really unusual.
I mentioned that we are
peculiar in our life cycles.
We have probably the latest
age at first reproduction
of any mammal.
It's very late.
We've got high
fertility, given how--
we've got low fertility
when you compare
us to like a pig, right?
We have singletons and we
spread them out pretty well,
whereas pigs will have a litter
of 13 piglets or whatever.
But for our body size and for
how late we begin reproducing,
we are very fecund.
We have a fertility
rate that's about 50%
higher than chimpanzees,
for instance,
in natural fertility
populations.
We have a super long
reproductive span.
You start reproducing
at around age 20 or so.
You end 45, 50.
That's a long time to be
reproducing for any mammal.
And we've got extensive periods
of overlap of dependence,
and this is another picture
from Brian Wood among the Hadza.
This beautiful Hadza family
with a mother with her four
dependent children
and her mother
who allows her to keep these
four beautiful children
alive by subsidizing her
foraging effort and her time,
and providing this babysitting.
I think this picture embodies
a lot of the peculiarities
of the human life cycle.
Among them include substantial
post-reproductive lifespan,
which is something that
most animals don't have.
So let's look at a little data.
I've got a database of about
1,400 mammal species here,
and I've just plotted things
out as a function of body size.
Biological things tend
to scale with body size,
and the modal mammal
weighs about 50 grams,
so there are lots
of little things.
There are fewer big things.
That's one of those things
that scales with body size.
So you put these on
double logarithmic axes,
and the red points are
primates, the black points
are all other mammals,
and the green are humans.
And so we can see that
for our body mass,
we have a very late age
at first reproduction.
We have a very long lifespan,
and we have low fertility,
but we're not quite
the same outlier
that we are in age at first
reproduction and lifespan.
We're kind of in with
all the other great apes
in terms of our fertility.
You don't really see
how freakishly different
we are-- how weird we
are until you start
to combine the parameters,
and this is also
a sort of engineering idea.
You have these different
parameters that
have different units on them.
Let's combine them and make some
dimensionless numbers and try
to get at the design
features of the organism,
and this life history theorist,
[INAUDIBLE] Chernov showed that
what I'm calling--
it's the ratio of age
at first reproduction
to total reproductive
lifespan, and I'm calling
that relative lifespan--
is constant across mammals,
and we can see for--
I've got the four
great apes here.
For the three
non-human great apes,
we can see it's
remarkably constant.
The same thing is
true for the-- it's
the product of age
at first reproduction
and annual fertilities.
I've called it
reproductive power here,
and it's a little more variable,
but it's constant enough
for comparative biology,
considering these things are
measured with a lot of slop.
How do humans fit in?
So our relative lifespan is
really right in the ballpark
of the other great apes.
What about our
reproductive power?
[WHISTLING]
Ooh.
Two, right?
So way more than
double what pretty much
all of the other mammals are.
This is the thing that's
really peculiar about humans.
So we live a long
time, but we actually
also make a lot of babies,
and those things typically
don't go together.
I suggested that--
a few years back,
that this pattern of
very long life and very
high reproductive power is
consistent with the strategy
known as bet hedging.
Humans are bet hedgers.
The long generation
length that comes
from a late age at
first reproduction
and a long reproductive
span, coupled
with relatively high
fertility, means
that we get to sample
multiple environments.
Think back to that plot
of temperature over time,
and zoom into a more
local time scale.
It's varying quite a bit, right?
There's decadal scale
variation that we
know is going on in the
Pleistocene in Africa,
and if you had great
information, you could say,
oh, I know that this is going
to be a great year to reproduce,
and you could pile all
your reproduction into it.
But if you're wrong,
you're completely hosed,
because you've put all
your eggs in one basket.
Bet hedging is all about
spreading out your risk,
doing it a lot, and trying to
sample a broad temporal series
of environments.
The essence of bet
hedging is trading off
the mean for a
reduction in variance,
and I should mention the
term comes from the race
track betting
strategy where you bet
at least a little money on
every single horse in a race.
And what that means
is that you're
guaranteed to lose
money every race,
but you're also guaranteed
not to lose it all,
because some horse has to win.
And you know, you don't
just lay it out at random.
Presumably you have
an idea about which
horse is going to win, but
you hedge yourself, right?
And so hedging, of course, is--
diversification in general
is the fundamental strategy
for risk management.
But why hedge bets and why
should humans, in particular,
need to hedge?
Why hedge?
Humans inherited the
legacy of slow reproduction
from the great apes.
We come from this
great ape stock,
and we have very low, in the
broader scheme of things,
reproductive capacity.
So under the best
of circumstances,
a chimpanzee population is
going to grow at about 1%
annually, if everything comes
together just perfectly.
And the higher the growth
rate, the less likely
a population will go extinct.
As humans moved into more
variable savanna woodland
environments, they
experienced greater variance,
and you can show that your
long run expectation is
essentially-- it's a
function of your mean,
but it's also a function
of your variance.
Variance pushes you
symmetrically around a mean,
and when you have an absorbing
boundary, that's a bad thing.
You want to avoid getting
pushed around that mean.
So prolific reproduction is sort
of the other way you do this.
Like if you're a
muscle or a sea urchin
or something that
lives in a highly
variable coastal
intertidal, what do you do?
You just produce
millions of gametes.
That's not an option for
humans, because we inherit
this legacy of the great apes.
So we're trying to
avoid extinction
given these enormous constraints
on our reproductive biology.
And again, another photo
that I think really
encapsulates so many of these
challenges that humans have,
and the embodiment of
uncertainty in our life
histories, is this incredible
portrait by Dorothea Lange--
this iconic photograph of
Oklahoma dust bowl refugees.
And here's a mother in
California with her infant
son--
her infant and her
young school-aged son.
This is weird.
We take it for granted,
because it's humans, you know.
You expect a young mother
has a bunch of young kids,
but it's really weird.
A chimpanzee mother-- birth
intervals of about 5 and 1/2
years in Gambia national
park in Tanzania--
another place where I've worked.
And she will wean her infant.
That starts that interval
right at about age five--
four or five--
and she will then never
invest in that child again
economically.
She will never share food
with that child again.
She will never nurse
that child again.
Could you imagine
doing that to this kid?
Sorry, five-year-old.
We've got a new baby.
You've got to make
it on your own.
That's not an
option for a human.
Even those of you who haven't
had kids probably know that,
right?
Sometimes you wonder
with Stanford students.
You have to explain that that
won't work, but you know.
I assume you guys know.
So adaptation to
uncertainty is embodied
in our very
reproductive biology.
Given its central
importance, it probably
comes into our economic
decision-making as well.
Now I'm going to--
I don't have much time left.
I'm going to talk about
two specific applications
very quickly.
So here is a schematic
model, and I just
put in the types of
economic decisions
that I tend to think
about as a reminder.
We've got these four
economic decisions
that are lotteries in
the sense that they
have variable payoffs.
These are decisions that
have variable payoffs
and we call them lotteries,
and in the standard economic
analysis, you have these
different lotteries
and they get aggregated
by a thing called utility.
The utility aggregates-- it
averages over these things,
and you're trying
to maximize that.
And when people start
thinking about well,
how do we mix economics
and evolutionary biology?
It's tempting to first simply
substitute fitness for utility,
but that's wrong
for two reasons.
First, no one but
sociopaths thinks
about maximizing their fitness.
You know, you say, oh, I must
have more babies and they--
and I must compete with--
people don't think that way.
That's not something,
and that's about
fitting into the
observations again.
But second and more
importantly, it
would be a terrible control
variable for your behavior,
because fitness is measured at
a time scale that's basically
greater than a human lifespan.
It's about your contribution
to future generations.
You can't sit there and have a
real-time feed of your fitness.
You need something
more proximate to use.
Fitness ends up being the
arbiter of what things work
and what things
don't, but you want
to have something
proximate that you
can use as a control variable
to respond adaptively
to a changing environment.
All right, so utility in
the standard economic model
aggregates and averages
over different lotteries.
In our model that I've
already shown you,
the lotteries are still there.
We've got these aggregators
at approximate level.
These are these proximate
motivational systems--
satiety, sexual satisfaction,
love of your children--
you know, whatever they are.
But what matters
is that they are
things that you can use to
guide your decisions over how
you decide to mix your
market basket, for example.
And then fitness is the
thing that aggregates
over the top of this.
This is a hierarchical
model that Mike Price and I
put together, and we've done
a bunch of things with it.
It turns out there are
a system of equations
that underlie this.
We can put some
constraints on there,
and there's actually
a whole talk
where I talk about
the constraints,
because it's sort of surprising
and interesting where
they come from.
And we have results.
Here are three, very quickly.
Distortion of decision weights,
kind of like prospect theory.
If the standard
economic analysis,
when you have a risky
decision to make,
is that you're trying to
maximize the expected value
of your utility--
and think about what
expected value means.
It means that you have a linear
combination of some weights.
They happen to be probabilities,
but they're decision weights
and some outcomes, right?
It's a linear combination.
It looks like people
aren't putting together
linear combinations of
weights and outcomes.
They're using some sort
of weird curvilinear thing
that Kahneman and
Tversky have suggested
looks kind of like that.
When we use fitness
as a criterion--
as an objective
function, what we get
is decision weights
that curve like that.
So that was cool.
Another thing is
high risk aversion
among the poorest people.
There is this idea--
it's kind of this
folklore, I think,
that poor people have nothing
to lose somehow, in the sense
that they're very
resource-poor and so they
should be willing-- they're
natural entrepreneurs.
They should be willing to take
risks because what have they
got to lose?
Well, what they
have to lose, when
you think of us as
biological entities,
is they have everything
to lose, right?
They're poor and so if
their financial decisions--
if their economic
decisions have an impact
on their survivability,
then we should expect them
to be actually risk averse,
and in this framework
it turns out that they're
extremely risk averse.
And then finally, we can
recover without any sort
of active choice these--
what look like
preference reversal.
Some of the classic
paradoxes of choice
that came about in the 1950s.
That's a little more technical,
but it's a cool result, too.
Just want to remind you,
as I get to my last point
here, about the diversity of
habitats that humans live in.
We come out onto the savanna,
we can live in these mixed rain
forests-- agricultural lands.
This is in Uganda again.
We live in the tundra,
inside the Arctic Circle.
Here's some Venezuelan Llanos,
home of swamps and big snakes.
This is where anacondas live.
People are very-- they're very
successful hunter-gatherers who
live there.
We live on the coastal
shore as fisherfolk.
We live on temperate prairies.
We have a wide
variety of habitats,
and presumably,
our choice calculus
should be a little different,
depending on where we're
actually making our decisions.
So as generalists with
tremendous capacity to learn,
it seems reasonable to suppose
that the human capacity
to make rational
decisions has an ontogeny,
meaning it has a development.
You have to learn a
little bit about it,
and I've developed
a simple model
of learning about one's
uncertain environment that
helps understand one of
the most vexing results
in this irrationality
literature, which is
inconsistent time preferences.
The fact that we value
waiting a day differently,
whether it's today or
whether it's next year.
We care a lot about waiting
from today till tomorrow,
but we don't care that much at
all a year, or a year and a day
from now.
Whatever.
It's a year from now.
This drives economists crazy.
It may seem common
sense to people.
I think that that's an
interesting insight,
but it does drive
economists crazy,
and it's one of the
fundamental anomalies.
So I have a simple model that
has basically four parts.
The first is that your
time preferences--
why do we care about the
present more than the future?
Well, a reasonable way
to think about that
is because there's
the chance that you
might die before you recover
a reward that you delay.
Or less dramatically,
that reward might go away.
Your friend might forget,
or it might be a resource
that gets swooped on.
So there's a hazard of
failure of this resource,
and you can then have a
time consistent prior, which
is like an exponential
distribution,
that you value all the
delays of the same amount
by the same amount.
That's your prior distribution,
consistent with the prior.
You can then go out and
learn about the environment,
but a lot of these important
economic decisions--
things about how what you
plant this year yields--
your yield nine months
from now, a year from now--
you don't have a
lot of opportunities
as a kid to learn about that.
You have a few,
so you're probably
at best going to learn
about it with uncertainty.
When you integrate
the uncertainty
of-- so the posterior looks
pretty good here, right?
I figure, again, I'm
on fairly safe ground.
Google Days, right?
Your posterior
looks pretty good,
but in fact, when
you integrate it
to give your posterior
predictive distribution,
all of a sudden you've got
all that uncertainty that
causes this big plateau
here, and it essentially
turns into what's known
as hyperbolic discounting.
So it's an inconsistency
in time preference,
because you've got
this fat tail that you
have to integrate over.
So uncertainly and discount
rate leads to inconsistent time
preferences.
There is the
exponential prediction.
The discount rate with no
uncertainty is exponential.
You add uncertainty,
and what you get
is essentially this
hyperbolic function.
I was really excited
when I read it,
because it's a
really simple model.
It's just a simple
little Bayesian model,
and it's like, wow, I've
really nailed it this time.
Turns out-- I then went
back to the literature.
It turns out a bunch
of people have said it,
which is always a
bittersweet moment.
On the one hand,
you're like, damn.
I thought I was so original.
But on the other hand, it means
that I had the same good idea
that Partha Dasgupta had, and
that's always a good thing.
So, you know-- you win
some, you lose some.
So I'm going to give
you three takeaways.
Maximizing fitness
distorts economic choices.
We've seen this repeatedly,
but it maximizes fitness,
and that's the direction
that selection is
going to push the population.
Uncertainty changes optimality
predictions qualitatively.
When you put uncertainty
into the game,
you get different answers,
and that evolutionary theory
has promise for providing a
comprehensive theory of choice.
It's very much a
work in progress.
I'm excited about
the potential here.
I'm excited about trying
to recruit some more
people to work on this, and I've
got to thank you for your time,
and I'm happy are
to entertain-- yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So I have basically a question
about the role of social
signaling in economic decisions,
and I'm thinking particularly
there's that game economists
like to point to as irrational,
where two people can
split a pile of money,
[INAUDIBLE] accepts or rejects--
JAMIE JONES: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Typically
if it's asymmetric,
second one will reject
and no one wins anything.
JAMIE JONES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Which to me
it seems like that's
because like in a
tribal environment,
you're trying to teach
other people don't try to--
JAMIE JONES: Costly punishment.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So this is another
area that has actually
gotten a lot more attention from
evolutionary anthropologists
and evolutionary biologists,
is what's sometimes
called our prosociality--
this intense sociality
that we have that's
reflected in these
food sharing networks,
but that we have the psychology
of, we don't like unfairness.
And when you play
the dictator game,
you punish people who don't
give what you perceive
to be fair offers,
and presumably this
relates to this
need for ensuring
cooperation in small
scale societies
and punishing cheaters.
Yeah.
Thanks for that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, a
related question.
So if we're really concerned
about comfort and survival
and things like
that, it's amazing
that humans will migrate
to some of the most
uncomfortable places, and we
will willingly venture out.
Why would a rational creature
go to the South Pole,
go to the moon, go to Mars?
JAMIE JONES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's dangerous.
They're not very pleasant.
And--
JAMIE JONES: Well--
AUDIENCE: Do we as
creatures-- is--
we tend to be rather curious,
and does that makes us somewhat
different from other animals?
JAMIE JONES: You know,
there are a lot--
I think that anything that
makes its living as a generalist
is going to be curious.
Lots of primates are
super curious, right?
I mean, if you live around
here and you have French doors,
you've possibly seen
raccoons at your door,
just sort of like
looking in, like, hey,
what's going on in there?
So I don't know if curiosity--
we certainly take
curiosity to another level.
All of those things--
you know, if you go to
Mars and you come back,
that's a pretty high
status thing to do, right?
You have a social
signaling going on--
if you come back.
No, right.
And if you think about
my Bayesian model,
how many opportunities do
you have to learn about what
the actual hazard is?
Suppose you have like
a really flat prior.
You've never seen anyone
go to Mars, so you know,
it could be anything, right?
So I think that that
sort of explains
some of the unusual decisions
that people seem to make.
Moving into the Arctic to live--
it may seem uncomfortable to us,
but you know, if you're Inuit,
you do pretty well, in general.
And there's a living
to be made there,
and people are
incredibly adaptable.
AUDIENCE: Question--
thanks for the talk.
Do you see any other species
that have environment--
that evolved in uncertain
environments that share
a similar pattern in
reproductive power or other
characteristics that--
JAMIE JONES: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I don't really know.
There is a-- so the
classic bet hedgers are--
there are a bunch of birds.
Again, local environment,
red-tailed hawks, right?
So a lot of the raptors
will do this thing
that's really kind of
perplexing at face value.
They'll lay clutches
of two eggs,
but only one will
ever fledge, and it
seems incredibly wasteful.
And it's a classic
bet hedging thing.
If that first one fails,
then the second one
is there, and the cost--
you're paying a little
bit of your mean.
You're paying out a
little insurance policy
to insure against
catastrophic failure.
So there are lots
of birds that engage
in this type of bet hedging.
Reproductive power,
as I've called it,
I have not seen
it in any mammal.
It's possible it
exists in other--
but you know, the way
the Chernov model works,
you have to-- for this model,
you have to be a mammal.
You could come up with these
sort of dimensionless design
features of different
life histories,
but it only works
for if you have
the same kind of general
reproductive biology.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in light
of your research, maybe
academically you wouldn't make
any recommendations like this,
but personally, do you
have recommendations
on how to motivate
people psychologically
and collectively to address
issues like climate change
that we're feeling
in the present now,
but we'll be feeling a
lot more in the future.
JAMIE JONES: Well, I have
pretty strong opinions
about the way we
value the future,
and I think that it seems like
it's a bit of a moral argument.
But when we say we want to take
some steps to mitigate climate
change now, whenever we do a
cost benefit analysis, what's
going to happen is
that you're going
to take a discount rate of the
value of an investment today
a couple hundred
years in the future.
And that's the real rub.
It's both the fact
that you're valuing
the present more than the
future, but you're also--
all these things play out
at very long time scales.
So you throw in a
4% discount rate,
and it's very difficult to
come up with a cost benefit
analysis that favors mitigation
now with a 4% discount
rate that pays out its
benefits in 200 years.
So I think, and I'm
not alone in this--
there are a bunch of
environmental economists who
are engaged in a very
vigorous debate on this--
that we should use much
lower discount rates
for thinking about
cost benefit analysis
with these long payoffs.
Martin Weitzman at
Harvard has suggested
using the absolute
lowest discount
rate that you can imagine
that makes it tenable, because
of this problem, and because
the tail risk of these outcomes
are so huge.
So that's something I take away
from this, like don't overvalue
the present.
But it's easy for me to do that.
I live in Palo Alto, right?
We all live in pretty
predictable environments.
We're quite privileged
people, and it's easy to say,
well, you know, we should
really value the future.
And this is some of the
work that my colleagues
who I showed you
briefly have done,
showing that if you're poor--
So like they're the classic
marshmallow experiments that
were done here at Stanford.
Give a kid a marshmallow
and walk away.
Say, "Don't eat that, all right?
Because if you do, that's
all you're getting.
But if it's still there when
I come back, you get two."
You walk away and it turns out
that these kids who struggle,
they're looking at this
marshmallow, and they're going,
"Oh god.
I want to eat the
marshmallow so bad."
It turns out that it
correlates very well--
your ability to
put off that reward
and get the larger reward
after a little delay--
predicts a lot of things
about your success in life.
It's really hard--
anthropologists have found it
really hard to go into places
and replicate these types
of economic games that
we play all the time,
including the dictator games--
these things that we
talked about before--
in part because
people are like, how
do I know you're going to be
back with your two marshmallows
that you talk about?
I've got to take that one
right now, thank you very much.
And so that's just a cautionary
tale, that it's easy for me
to say, we should
value the future more,
because I have a pretty
low discount rate because I
live in Palo Alto.
As a society, I think we
should be modeling the future--
valuing the future
more than we do.
That's a really long answer
to a pretty straightforward
question.
Yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: How does
our evolution history
play out when we are not
200 people in a small band?
But we have 7 billion people
[INAUDIBLE] that we construct?
JAMIE JONES: Yeah.
That's a vexing problem, that
we sort of develop these ingroup
and outgroup identities,
and that they probably
are very functional when you
live in a band-like society,
because your ingroup is
really your everything.
It's maybe not so
functional when
you make the rest of
the world your outgroup,
and the same sort
of rules of morality
don't apply to them
and that sort of thing.
That's a real problem,
and solving that--
there's a prize for someone,
is if we can figure out
how to really begin
to address that.
Equally importantly,
in the world
we live in, when
you're a peasant farmer
and you plant yams
and some maize
and whatever, you place your
bet and then you tend it
and you hopefully get
a big payoff, right?
There is a direct causal
interpretation of what you do
and what you get.
In the world we live in, we
have all this complexity,
and we don't necessarily pay
the costs for bad decisions
right away, and I think that
makes it very hard to learn
about good decision-making.
And so there are
a number of people
who've developed sort of the
curricula for teaching kids
how to make risky decisions.
I think that giving
kids some responsibility
and getting them
some skin in the game
is a really important thing.
So that's a little
off of your question,
but I think that that's another
real challenge to thinking
about how our brains were
designed to make decisions
and the types of
environments in which we
have to do it now-- many of us.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If we predict
greatly increased variability
in the near future,
what would you predict
with those functions, e.g.
more longevity or things
like that in this?
JAMIE JONES: Well
first of all, we
have to get through this
possible bottleneck, right?
And I say that flippantly
because otherwise I'd just
descend into depression, right?
Sure, it's
conceivable that there
could be more selection on even
more spread-out reproduction.
The thing is that--
a really interesting
observation that we
make in development
economics and demography
is that as soon
as you can ensure
the more-or-less certain
survival of your kids
to reproductive age,
people voluntarily
reduce their fertility.
And so we had this model called
the Demographic Transition
model and it predicted the time
scale over which has happened,
and it seemed to explain the
historical data very well.
And then late in the 20th
century, these places--
a lot of places in the
Middle East and North Africa
and in Asia--
in the tiger
economies, fertility
fell like that as soon as kids
could be counted on to survive.
And so-- yeah.
If our technological
and social technologies
can keep up with ensuring
the child survivorship
and keeping it favoring
economic investment,
then that sort of relaxes
the selection pressure
to spread everything
out, for sure.
And I think that that should
be a goal that we have.
If we want to avoid negative
population consequences,
make sure that kids
survive to adulthood,
because that changes everything
about people's investments,
and that's really what this--
given that you can't
affect that as a hominin
a million years ago, you
don't have the technology
to really mitigate that.
So what you do is you
spread everything out.
But if we have the chance
to actually solve it, then
that's the better
solution probably,
and that also reduces the
selective pressure, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks a lot.
It was fun.